welcome to the first video in my series
of reviews I'm gonna be doing in 2018 my
new year's resolution this year was that
I would review one film each month all
year that came out pre 1970 and my very
first one is 12 Angry Men released in
1957 starring Henry Fonda who's one man
serving his jury duty amongst 11 others
who have just heard a murder case
they've gone over all the details in
courts they've heard all of the
arguments they've heard the defense now
they're in a room trying to find out if
this boy is guilty or not if he's guilty
they're gonna send him to the electric
chair and he will be killed it's a very
young kid we get one shot of him early
on in the film and just from that one
shot we immediately feel sympathy just
this one image of this boy is all we get
to see of him and we know something
isn't right early in the film the 12
guys think hey maybe we can get out of
here pretty quick one of them has
tickets to a baseball game all of them
seem to think the kids guilty so they
called their first vote and sure enough
Henry Fonda is the only man there who
thinks there's a reasonable doubt and he
spends the next 90 minutes of this film
trying to convince the 11 other men that
that doubt could be real the first time
I saw this movie I was probably 11 or 12
I was very young I was over at my
sister's house dog-sitting we had a
golden retriever at the time and my
sister was gonna be out for a few days
and so I was helping her out by making
sure that our golden retriever was taken
care of and she was fed and she went
potty and all that stuff and there was a
really terrible thunderstorm and I was
watching Dragonball Z on TV my sister
had satellite TV and the storm knocked
out the satellite and suddenly
Dragonball Z was no longer an option so
I began to sift through her collection
of VHS tapes and I came across 12 Angry
Men now 11 12 year-old kid in the 90s
isn't exactly excited about watching a
black-and-white movie but I wanted to
because I thought the plot was
interesting and I popped in that VHS
tape and if you had told that
eleven-year-old hey
you're gonna be happy the power went out
for the TV and you're gonna be happy
that you didn't get to see Dragon Ball Z
today because this movie is that good he
wouldn't have believed you
but that eleven-year-old kid was riveted
from scene one and this guy talking you
today still feels the same way this
movie is a masterpiece that term gets
thrown around a lot it's a very easy
thing to say about great films like this
but this movie is one of the best this
is one of the very few films that I will
call perfect Ridley Scott's original
alien perhaps Raiders of the Lost Ark
jaws 2001 Space Odyssey
I mean these are films that are flawless
in my mind movies that just they don't
have you can't find anything wrong with
them I mean film is subjective in the
long run and you can say I don't like
Raiders a lost art because it isn't for
me but if you're the type of person who
really likes to examine film and who
wants to write or make films you look to
films like 12 Angry Men as the example
of how to do it perfectly the way Sydney
Lumia director helmed this film was
maximum claustrophobia maximum suspense
we learn early on is the hottest day of
the year every single character is
sweating safer one juror who says he
doesn't sweat except for the very
beginning and the very end it is all in
one location and you don't have much
room to move
so Sydney Liu may used everything at his
disposal to make this film as
interesting and as compelling as
possible
he Helms this like it's an action film
but all he can use is the camera
movements and the characters that are in
the film there are so many shots in 12
Angry Men that send chills down my spine
as Henry Fonda continues to try to chip
away at why other people in this room
don't have reasonable doubt and there
are moments that come about that are
just some of the best in cinematic
history as the 12 guys filter into the
room at the beginning you may not notice
this while watching it because it's just
so seamless but this is all one take the
camera flows through the room
and we could introduce to every single
character and we learn an integral piece
of information about each man in this
shot and the way
Sydney lumens the camera with the
characters you begin to feel like you're
watching multiple shots this is
something that Spielberg does very well
he puts the characters in different
positions and moves the camera all
around the room to create wide Smid z'
and close-ups even though there aren't
any cuts and 12 Angry Men has a great
example of this just in the opening and
we learn about this case through these
characters in the way they talk about it
since the film begins with the court
case ending and the jurors filtering
into this room we only learn the details
of the case through what the members of
the jury say and so it makes us feel
like we're members of the jury at the
beginning you're like okay yeah it seems
like it's pretty obvious kids guilty all
right convince me otherwise and then
Henry Fonda says hey I I just think it's
possible what do you mean it's not
possible well you saw what the kid was
doing I'm Lee J Cobb and I'm a genius
actor you can't say I'm not your work
your heart out for these kids I joke but
Lee Jay Cobb is phenomenal here he plays
a very very damaged character and as the
film continues you began to realize that
there is some personal vengeance perhaps
underneath the surface of why he would
like to see this kid go to the chair and
as Henry Fonda continues to pressure
people who think the kid is guilty you
learn that perhaps it's not all facts
for some of these people some of them
might have other agendas and there's an
amazing aspect of this film that deals
with personal prejudice when one
character in particular continues to
reference this kid who comes from a slum
and is very poor as one of them you
begin to realize okay you have other
motives and there's another member of
the jury who also has lived in a slum
his whole life and so this creates some
amazing tension and some really
beautiful character work there's also
really
haunting dialogue that sticks with you
long after the film particularly this
one encounter in the bathroom for Henry
Fonda is washing his face and one of the
guys is in there and he's like hey
supposing this kid really did knife his
father and you all talk us out of it
it's like oh yeah I would suck
because by then you've started sort of
side with Fonda as he expresses his
doubt when that guy says that you're
thinking to yourself yeah that would be
bad
the film is wise to show why Henry
Fonda's position is smart and why he's
clever to have reasonable doubt but you
can also understand why each member who
thinks the kid is guilty thinks that
remarkably except for a few phrases
characters say this movie isn't dated
that's large in part due to the fact
that it all takes place in one room and
everyone's wearing a suit or some sort
of nice clothing that has remained sort
of in style form of clothing for a
really long time but you can actually
watch this movie in 2018 and except for
the fact that it's black and white and
you have the knowledge that it was made
in the 50s it doesn't seem that way
nobody talks like this see now listen to
me I'm gonna tell you this thing we're
supposed to see right now if you've
never seen 12 Angry Men I'm gonna
mention a few specific moments that I
love that are spoilery I implore you to
please see the film obviously I am
recommending it if you've if you've
never seen a black and white movie
because I'm sure some of my viewers
haven't and I'm not gonna judge you for
that if you've never seen a black and
white movie make this be the first one
you see because it's one of the best
we're gonna talk about a few specific
moments I love one of them being the
fact that Fonda starts to bate more
excitable members of the jury into
saying things that prove his case like
this scene perhaps you'd like to pull
the switch Brothers kid you better would
I feel sorry for you what it must feel
like to want to pull the switch ever
since you walked into this room you've
been acting like a self-appointed public
Avenger you want to see this boy die
because you personally wanted not
because of the facts you're a sadist
you don't really mean you'll kill me do
you every single time I see this movie
without fail that gives me chills it's
so brilliantly executed the way he uses
the camera Sidney Lumet to position it
around people's faces to create the
feeling of tension or the feeling of
whoever is in power in that moment for
most of the beginning of the film when
Henry Fonda's trying to convince the
others the camera is above him or at
level with him towards the end of the
film however as he gets other people
decide with him you see that camera
going lower and now he's above the
camera superior it makes his enemies so
to speak in the room feel inferior
I mean it's genius
it's movie's perfect there is not a
single thing wrong with it and one of
the best moments in movie history is the
Switchblade sequence where Henry Fonda
says look this supposed one an only
knife that this kid killed his dad with
I found one myself
and he just slams it into the table
right next to the exhibit and the script
is so wise to use specific reasons why
each member of the jury might find the
kid guilty or not guilty based off of
their personal life like one of the last
few guys has glasses and the ultimate
point that gets under his skin is the
woman who supposedly saw this kid do it
had those marks on her nose that glasses
cause meaning that she probably wasn't
wearing her glasses when she rolled over
in bed at night and saw this murder
happen allegedly and when that point is
brought out the juror who wears glasses
is like I'm convinced not guilty the
screenplay is one of the best this movie
is one of the best every single time I
watch it I feel inspired it's shocking
how great a film is in one location it's
honestly mesmerizing and the back and
forth between protagonist Henry Fonda
and antagonist
Lee Jacob
is so well done that at the end of the
film a simple gesture of helping the
other man into his suit coat is
beautiful and touching and as the men
dispersed out of the court and one of
them introduces himself and they both
say their names you realize oh
they've never said their names once you
don't realize these things because the
film is just that great if you have
never seen 12 Angry Men you've got to
see it 12 Angry Men of course gets an A
plus guys thank you so much as always
for watching I'm gonna be doing more of
these reviews every month pre-1970s
films I want to bring more attention to
this era of filmmaking because I feel
like YouTube has become a 1980s and 90s
and early 2000s cesspool which is fine
those that's a cool era but there needs
to be more talk about films like this
because these are the films that shaped
the landscape of movies today guys thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get steppen eyes
[Music]